dominic lapointe d'abord à combien
évaluez-vous les risques de récession au
canada on est d'accord ac avec les
chiffres qui ont été avancés donc en 40
et 50% gex et pas nécessairement le
chiffre qui les plus importants sont
attendus de caractériser quel type de
récession parce qu'en bout de ligne
peut-être pas une différence énorme
entre ce que nous on continue prévoir
une croissance économique est très
faible à la fin de l'année et une
récession qui serait somme toute modéré
si vraiment important c'est comment
l'inflation va finir par des cendres
ouvrez votre évaluation avoue serge est
bien avec
yoyo un changement radical de politique
monétaire américaine au cours de la
dernière semaine et demie et donc la
banque centrale américaine a augmenté
ses taux de trois quarts de point et ont
laissé entendre qu'ils vont monter
encore beaucoup plus alors qu'auparavant
on s'attendait à avoir des taux
d'intérêt de 2 à 3% pour sortir de cette
inflation les marchés se sont rendus
compte que c'était pour être beaucoup
plus haut donc l'atterrissage des
économies ne sera pas sans douleur alors
est ce que robin d'une récession ou une
baisse de production c'est des chiffres
présentement qui sont très difficiles à
évaluer il ya énormément d'incertitudes
mais on doit s'attendre à un
atterrissage dans la douleur dans la
douleur donc est-ce que cet atterrissage
dans la douleur se fait quand même dans
un contexte où le canada et le québec
serait en meilleure position qu'en 2008
ou en 2000 pour y faire face par exemple
dominique lapointe je pense que c'est
indéniable en 2000 en fait il n'y a pas
eu de récession canadiens ont une
récession assez modérée aux états unis
lorsqu'on parle de 2008 la récession et
provenaient des états unis puis c'est
difficile de comparer l'effondrement
historique du marché immobilier aux
états unis qu'on n'avait jamais vu puis
un peu une débâcle financière qui était
bâtie sur 10 ans d'ingénierie financière
qui était somme toute un peu malsaine on
n'est pas dans les mêmes types de
déséquilibre en ce moment même si oui au
canada on a quand même vu naître
réhabilité au point de vue de
l'immobilier qui a pas aux états unis en
ce moment mais est ce qu'on peut dire
serge coulombe que notre économie et
plus résiliente plus solide est ce qu'on
est capable de faire face à ce qui s'en
vient avec plus de solidité que par les
récessions passées vous que je dirais
que par rapport à d'autres pays oui
parce que par rapport aux récessions
passées c'est pas le même type de
récession qu'on va avoir une récession
qui provient de l'offre mais par rapport
aux autres pays c'est clair pour deux
raisons importantes
la première c'est que le canada est un
important producteur de ressources
naturelles et de ce côté-là l'ukraine et
la russie deux pays qui sont
présentement en guerre sont des
concurrents donc la hausse des prix des
matières premières qui apparaissent
malheureusement positive aux
consommateurs sur les rayons d'épicerie
son augmente la marge de profit des
producteurs canadiens la deuxième c'est
qu'on dispose comme les états unis
contrairement aux yeux aux européens
d'une banque centrale indépendante qui
peut donc ajuster à la hausse le taux
d'intérêt à sa guise sans se soucier
comme la banque centrale européenne doit
se soucier de l'italie qui a déjà une
prime de risque de 2 3 points et demi
par rapport à l'allemagne à la france
donc la banque centrale européenne a
vraiment les mains liées en ce qui
concerne des hausses de taux doc au
canada la banque saderat et armés comme
la banque centrale américaine pour
lutter contre l'inflation avec des roses
vous avez parlé du pétrole puis de
l'énergie juste un mot serge coulombe là
dessus est ce que ça protège compte tenu
de la force du secteur de l'énergie au
canada le canada d'une récession
police fermant met donc le secteur
manufacturier va clairement être touché
négativement ainsi que le secteur des
services mais il va y avoir
le secteur énergétique qui ne qui n'est
pas uniquement situé dans l'ouest mais
dans le nord de l'ontario dans le nord
du québec en saskatchewan mêmes
à terre neuve donc l'économie canadienne
va avoir une base solide pour permettre
au gouvernement d'avoir des recettes
budgétaires plus que suffisant à mon
avis pour passer à travers
cette période et le québec dominic
lapointe comment le québec va se
comporter dans le contexte actuel pour
être honnête ça va être difficile
d'éviter une récession au canada comme
au québec s'il ya une récession
importante aux états unis on a encore
80% du commerce international qui est
avec notre partenaire donc peu importe
si on ne lui on est dans le camp du
québec fait assez bien le taux de
chômage est allé très bord pendant la
pandémie aussi les ménages québécois en
moyenne ont accumulé un peu plus des
pagnes qu'ils avaient par le passé on
sait quelque chose que l'on n'avait
peut-être pas autant cependant quelques
mois des pannes accumulé donc ça peut
aider mais de manière générale si aux
états unis il ya une contraction du pib
ça va être difficile pour l'économie du
québec aussi est ce que vous pensez de
mener que la pointe qu'on approche quand
même un point de rupture parce que les
ménages doivent composer avec une hausse
de 10% des prix des aliments et les prix
de l'essence on est dans du vin et 30 40
% quand on compare ça dépend avec quel
moment on compare mais est-ce qu'on
approche d'un point de rupture pour les
consommateurs mais on a appris dans les
deux dernières années que pour la
plupart des ménages au canada en raison
qu'on a soutenu l'emploi on a soutenu la
consommation et on a fait des transferts
généreux pour la plupart des ménages de
situation financière s'est améliorée
pendant la pandémie donc même avec les
hausses de taux on estime que les
consommateurs peuvent faire face par
contre une minorité de consommateurs ou
de déménager cette minorité est le prix
de l'emploi par la pandémie qui elle est
beaucoup plus à risque s'est endettée
beaucoup plus surtout avec les
hypothèques et c'est vraiment pour ces
gens là qu'on doit créer en ce moment
d'ailleurs vous nous avez sorti un
graphique intéressant serge coup l'homme
qui vient de la banque fédérale de
dallas qui était retenu repris dans des
économistes du 9 juin qui montrent
clairement que les prix des propriétés à
l'intérieur du g7 la basse et au canada
que les prix ont le plus augmenté ça
nous dit quoi ce graphique pour vous eh
bien ça nous dit que le canada est de
loin et là de très très loin le pays qui
a vu la plus forte augmentation du prix
des maisons depuis l'an 2000 et elle
fait vraiment exceptionnel ajoute un
autre pays dans le monde qui peut se
comparer à nous c'est la nouvelle
zélande et d'ailleurs des économistes
présentement spécialiste des marchés
immobiliers s'attendent à une baisse du
prix des maisons d'environ 25 pour cent
au canada et même les prix seraient
encore à un niveau relativement élevé
donc oui c'est un secteur qui est
extrêmement sensible à la hausse des
taux d'intérêt c'est le secteur qui est
le plus sensible on entend déjà les
effets d'ailleurs tout à fait oui déjà
des baisses du prix
des maisons mais un autre indicateur
important à regarder c'est la croissance
des salaires qui au début de la poussée
inflationniste les salaires au canada
ont augmenté de 2 % par année alors que
l'inflation était rendu à 5 pour cela
mais au cours des derniers mois il ya eu
des hausses importantes de la croissance
des salaires au canada et aux états-unis
au canada on est rendu à 4%
d'augmentation et aux etats-unis à plus
de 5 pour ça ça donne à penser que
ça donne à penser que l'inflation est en
train de s'incruster ce qui fera en
sorte que la guerre contre l'inflation
avait par la banque du canada devra sera
encore plus difficile on devrait
probablement augmenter encore les taux
d'intérêt de façon plus rapide et les
garder élevé durant une période plus
longue est ce qu'on peut faire autrement
que de compter sur la banque centrale
dominique lapointe pour faire cette
guerre justement à l'inflation on
entendait la ministre frieden
d'aujourd'hui qui dit que le
gouvernement a déjà mis en place
beaucoup de mesures pour aider les gens
à faire face à l'inflation est ce qu'est
ce que c'est c'est approprié ce plan là
justement pour contribuer à la lutte à
l'inflation on peut difficilement faire
autre chose au point de vue du
gouvernement
lorsqu'on regarde les mesures c'est
toujours intéressant pour des ménages
qui ont plus de difficultés en ce moment
1 pour une famille normale qui voient
dans leur panier de consommation
augmenter de quelques milliers de
dollars cette année ça va toujours
rester une aide partielle ou la
mentionner c'est la banque centrale qui
fait le gros du travail en baisse à
radama généralisée mais malheureusement
tant qu'on va recevoir des chocs d'offre
mondiale comme les régions politique la
russie qui a envahi l'ukraine peu
importe la hausse des taux d'intérêts ça
va alimenter l'inflation
ouais exactement et ça on n'a pas
beaucoup de prise là dessus est ce que
ce sont des mesures qui sont utiles pour
vous serge coulombe à mon avis les
mesures died aux ménages par les
transferts
peuvent s'expliquer que comme état
rationnelle du point de vue de l'équité
mais comme vous l'avez mentionné au
début de votre émission présentement le
problème c'est que l'offre est très
inférieure à la demande de biens et
services partout dans le monde et au
canada particulièrement on manque de
main d'oeuvre donc et la banque du
canada va va exercer un impact sur
l'inflation en baissant la demande quand
on augmente les taux d'intérêt ont fait
la demande donc c'est mal vu présenta
c'est contre productif de voir que les
gouvernements
injectent de nouvelles liquidités font
des transferts aux ménages même si c'est
logique du point de vue politique il
faut protéger les ménages et les agents
qui sont les plus vulnérables
du point de vue macroéconomique
ça semble contre-productif on ne peut
pas apaiser sur les fraises fortement
avec la politique monétaire et puis
continuer à donner de l' accélération
avec la politique budgétaire dont le
déficit fédéral et déjà et elle est
encore élevé me suivre ayant donné que
la pointe un mot en terminant la hausse
du 13 juillet de la banque du canada
sera 2 75 points de base selon noter
qu'ils pourraient et selon votre équipe
serge oui aussi à 75 points de base ok
excellent merci beaucoup monsieur pour
cette analyse ce soir c'était très
intéressant merci beaucoup merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh